why every so many hundred years the
Zionist get slaughtered because Hitler
knew how to deal with these people they
probably made a program so they can
create a state of Israel first of all
it's lovely to see Jeremy Corbin make a
return to Frontline politics secondly I
don't think it's a good idea to use
Hitler as your role model I've got a
little idea how about we stop glorifying
hate figures and people who've committed
atrocities and killed millions of people
simply because of their belief system or
their immutable characteristics and
actually start respecting people who are
trying to bring us together little
thought for the day